- Why did the US go to war in Iraq?
- [Man] In the early
stages of evacuations.
- Growing up, the
narrative was always oil.
We went to Iraq to get oil,
like America always does.
- We might find ourselves
without adequate supplies
of energy in the future.
- [Reporter] All major
oil fields in the south
are now under coaliltion control.
- But that's kind of the lazy explanation,
it's not quite it.
Oil is a part of it but
it's not the main reason.
We went to war in Iraq
because several powerful
American men wanted to.
Some of them thought it
was vital, we had to.
Others just wanted to
project American power.
But either way, here
we are 18 years later,
nearly 10,000 Americans dead,
over 200,000 Iraqis dead,
over a trillion tax dollars spent.
And the result?
A Middle East that is
less stable than ever
in part because of the US presence
and really because of it.
How did this happen?
I mean, I grew up and lived through this.
I studied it as an undergrad,
I studied it in grad school,
and yet it's taken me until
now to really take a hard look
and to really understand
exactly what happened.
So this is how the US stole Iraq.
- [Man] Saddam Hussein
is a tyrant, a murderer,
and a man who has started two wars.
He's clearly someone who
cannot be trusted or believed.
- All right, so it's the night of 9/11,
the country is reeling.
Who did this terrible thing and why?
How should the US respond?
And it became clear very soon
amongst intelligence and
counter-terrorism people
that al-Qaeda was behind it,
this terrorist group that was
mainly based in Afghanistan.
Later that night, the night of 9/11,
over at the Pentagon,
which earlier that day had
been hit by an airplane,
a memo comes in from the
Deputy Secretary of State.
The memo is urgent.
It's for the Defense Intelligence Agency,
the people who've spent their time
doing all the intelligence
for war and other defense purposes.
And this memo tells
the intelligence agents
not to look into al-Qaeda,
the people they know did it,
but instead to look into ways
Iraq has been involved in
terrorism for the previous decade.
The intelligence agents who got this memo
sort of scratched their
head and were like,
"Wait what? What's going on here?"
These people were very
familiar with the intel
and they knew that this attack
had come from al-Qaeda in Afghanistan.
Afghanistan is more than 1,000
kilometers away from Iraq.
It is a completely different place,
they speak a different language,
has nothing to do with Iraq.
Afghanistan and Iraq
are totally different.
We had just been attacked by al-Qaeda,
and yet the Deputy Secretary of Defense
is asking for information about Iraq
and its ties to terrorism.
The person who sent this memo
was the Deputy Secretary
of State Paul Wolfowitz,
and he was just getting started.
(gentle music)
A few days after 9/11,
the president gathers
all of his top advisors
out at his forest retreat right
outside of Washington, DC.
They were there to discuss how
to respond to these attacks.
The focus of this discussion
was, of course, Afghanistan.
How do we retaliate against al-Qaeda,
this terrorist group that has been given
sort of a safe haven by the
government of Afghanistan?
So they're sitting in some
conference room in some lodge
in this forest retreat
debating how they're gonna
retaliate against al-Qaeda,
and who pipes up again but
this guy, Paul Wolfowitz?
This time with the support of his boss,
Secretary of Defense Donald Rumsfeld.
So Wolfowitz pipes up and he's like,
"You know, 9/11 was a
pretty sophisticated attack.
"There's no way that this
ragtag terror group of al-Qaeda
"could have pulled it off all alone.
"They probably had help
from Saddam in Iraq."
And then Wolfowitz says
that "when it comes to global terrorism,
"Saddam is actually
the head of the snake."
He actually said that,
basically saying that Saddam
is behind all of this.
And everyone in the room is sort of like,
"Um, what the hell is
this guy talking about?
"Saddam Hussein is a really bad guy,
"but he's not the head of the snake
"of international terrorism."
All these people,
these very informed international
advisors. (chuckles)
Oh man, after some astonished glances,
the head of the Counterterrorism Center
raises his hands and says,
"Mr. President," quote,
"we were attacked on
9/11 by Osama Bin Laden
"and al-Qaeda in Afghanistan.
"Saddam Hussein and Iraq has
nothing to do with this."
It's just like, I'm sorry,
I feel like as an eighth
grader at this time
I was asking these questions.
I was like, "Is Iraq the
same as Afghanistan?"
And here are the leaders of
our country having to explain
that Saddam Hussein has nothing to do
with Afghanistan and al-Qaeda.
So this meeting at Camp David,
they move on and they keep
talking about these plans
to bomb al-Qaeda.
But Paul Wolfowitz is stubborn
and he does not give up.
Later that day there's a
break in all of the meetings,
it's like the afternoon.
Attorney General John
Ashcroft is playing the piano
in this sort of lobby
and a few others are singing along
these piano spirituals that he's playing.
Condoleezza Rice is one of
these people singing along.
President Bush is
sitting over by the fire.
It's this rustic cabin, it's all cozy.
He's drinking a cup of coffee.
And who cozies up to him at
the fire but Paul Wolfowitz?
And Bush is like, "Uh, here we go again."
So he's like, "Listen, check out my plan.
"Half of Iraq's people
live either way up here
"where they don't like Saddam.
"They're Kurds, they've
been brutalized by Saddam,
"they do not like him.
"Or they live way down here in the south
"which is right near the border
of our good friend Kuwait.
"We could easily come into Iraq
"and take both of these
big population centers.
"Oh, and in doing so,"
says Paul Wolfowitz,
"we could naturally take the
major oil fields in Iraq,
"thus cutting off Saddam from
his main revenue source."
Or, in other words,
he said making Saddam, quote,
"the Mayor of Baghdad."
He would only have power in Baghdad,
he would be cut off from the
north and south of his country.
In this moment I can almost
see George Bush's ears
literally perking up when
he hears this last part
about cutting off the oil supply.
After all, Bush was a former Texas oilman
and he knew the importance
of having access to oil.
So this plan sort of intrigued Bush
and he literally said to
Paul Wolfowitz, quote,
"Why didn't you bring
this up in the meeting?"
And Wolfowitz is like,
"Well, I didn't wanna step
on the toes of my superiors."
Wolfowitz, we know you just wanted
to cozy up against the president
and plant this seed of how it
would be to take over Iraq.
(gentle music)
So put yourself in George
Bush's shoes for a second.
Your country was just brutally
attacked on your watch,
and you are completely
at a loss of what to do.
There's no clear easy
target to retaliate against.
After a day of meetings,
of sitting around trying to
figure out how to retaliate,
George Bush is realizing
that retaliating against
a tiny group of terrorists
living in caves in Afghanistan
is like trying to hit
smoke with a baseball bat.
Kind of impossible.
What George Bush wanted
and felt like he needed,
and it turns out
what a lot of American
lawmakers also wanted,
was a clear decisive target.
Not to try to hit smoke
with a baseball bat,
but a nice solid hit.
A home run.
So I believe this day at Camp David,
four days after 9/11,
is when President Bush decided
that he would find a way to invade Iraq,
to make Americans and himself feel like
he was actually doing
something definitive,
like toppling dictators,
as a rebuttal to the
terrible attacks of 9/11.
Even though Iraq had
nothing to do with al-Qaeda,
he and his people around
him would find a way
to make a connection.
(gentle music)
- If they're harboring terrorists,
why not go in and get them?
- Well, the evidence is pretty conclusive
that the Iraqis have
indeed harbored terrorists.
- So, over the next year,
this seed that Paul Wolfowitz
really planted and nourished
in George Bush's mind
starts to spread to everyone around him,
and they start to find a way
to sell the American public
on this idea of war with Iraq.
They get the British on board
and soon there's a full-blown debate
which revolves around this story
that Saddam has really
big terrible weapons
and that he will likely give
those weapons to terrorists
who will strike the United States
in another 9/11-type attack but way worse.
- The debate about the war
against Iraq has divided many
along the political spectrum.
- Hundreds of millions of dollars
and I think that that is unnecessary.
- Real concern about this Russian war.
- And Bush kept saying
weapons of mass destruction
over and over again.
He learned that short phrase.
- Very dangerous weapons
of mass destruction
into this country.
- But wait, hold on a
second, don't be fooled.
The lead-up to the Iraq
War is often remembered
as this robust debate about WMDs,
weapons of mass destruction.
- Saddam Hussein will continue
to increase his capacity
to wage biological and chemical warfare
and will keep trying to
develop nuclear weapons.
- But I'm here to tell you
that you need to think
differently about it.
The decision to go to war
in Iraq was already made.
It was made moments after 9/11
when a small group of powerful men
imagined a glorious military campaign
to liberate oppressed
Iraqis and topple a dictator
to make themselves and their country
feel like we got a home
run after we were attacked.
From there, everything
molded to fit that decision.
Did Saddam Hussein have
weapons of mass destruction?
Did he wanna give those to terrorists?
No, there was no evidence.
The little evidence there was
was threadbare and super speculative.
But these guys turned into
sort of like tea-leaf readers
where you can look at the tea leaves
and see whatever you need to
to support the decision that
they made many months earlier.
And it wasn't just these guys.
Soon, this vision of toppling Saddam
and having this American victory
spread to the American Congress,
Republicans and Democrats who
were also getting on board
with this idea of
America, a force for good,
toppling the bad guy.
It's a really wild study
in human psychology.
When you're a true believer in something,
you really really believe
that you need to do something.
Everything you see confirms
what you want to believe
or what you need to believe.
We all do it,
but it's just scary when
our leaders are doing this,
and they're doing it on
beliefs and decisions
that have deep ramifications
for human suffering.
So yeah, you can go over the
debates and the intelligence
and the back and forth on whether or not
Saddam had weapons of mass destruction.
It was all a show to
help these people confirm
what they'd already
decided they wanted to do.
So by the end,
after weapons inspectors
had done 700 inspections
and found no weapons,
this group of guys eventually
just start resorting
to full-on lying.
Dick Cheney gets up in
his speech and says.
- Simply stated, there is no doubt
that Saddam Hussein now has
weapons of mass destruction.
- Well, there was plenty of doubt.
In fact, he simply stated,
there can be no evidence
that Saddam has WMDs
was the reality at the time.
Even the Secretary of State, Colin Powell,
who was totally against
this fantasy-filled vision
of going and invading Iraq,
even him eventually got on board,
painstakingly getting in front of the UN
and going over a bunch of
thin or non-existent evidence
and claiming that it was watertight.
- My colleagues, every
statement that I make today
is backed up by sources, solid sources.
These are not assertions.
What we're giving you
are facts and conclusions
based on solid intelligence.
- Solid intelligence, no no no no.
These are words that Colin
Powell has lived to regret
for the rest of his life.
A lot of people saw Colin Powell
as the one sane guy in the room.
And so here at the UN
when he's drinking the Kool-Aid
and backing this intelligence,
a lot of people got on board.
By October 10th, 2002,
the US Congress was fully on board.
Almost all the Republicans in the chamber
as well as a sizeable group of Democrats
voted to authorize the US
to use force against Iraq.
- [Man] Senate Joint Resolution 45
to authorize the use of
United States Armed Forces
against Iraq.
- He has said he wants the
power to be able to go to war.
This seems completely
consistent with that request
that we say, "Yes, Mr. President,
"you have that power to go to war."
- This resolution gives the
president the authority he needs
to confront the threat posed by Iraq.
- Saddam Hussein and his sons
must leave Iraq within 48 hours.
- And then it happened.
- [Reporter] Sirens went off in Baghdad
just a few minutes ago.
An air raid is in progress over Baghdad.
- Explosions in Baghdad.
- [Bush] Our nation enters
this conflict reluctantly.
- [Reporter] You could have a report
that an estimated 30 Iraqis
surrendered at the border.
(dramatic music)
(jet whooshes)
(triumphal music)
- Two months after the invasion,
George Bush gives a speech
on an aircraft carrier
with this giant sign that says,
quote, "Mission accomplished."
This is the type of thing
Bush surely was dreaming about
while he was sitting by
the fire at Camp David,
drinking coffee,
listening to Paul
Wolfowitz explain the plan
to take over Iraq.
Big triumphant America
just toppled the dictator.
Mission accomplished.
But this is the part of the story
when all of the dreams, the fantasies,
the visions of glory start to topple.
Mission accomplished was
really mission just beginning.
(gentle music)
One of the first things that the US did
when they took over Baghdad
was they dissolved the
huge Iraqi military.
They just said, "No, we
don't want you anymore.
"All of you commanders and
leaders, soldiers, you're out.
"We're gonna start fresh."
In typical simplistic thinking
of these visionary leaders,
the idea was that doing
so would allow them
to start totally fresh with a new army,
completely rid of any sort of
influence of Saddam Hussein.
So now you have a bunch
of ex-Iraqi army members
who are angry at the United
States and unemployed.
Oh, and all of them have
extensive military experience.
- There is a large number
of former Iraqi soldiers
that are unemployed now.
That is a huge concern.
- It is just painful.
What a terrible decision.
So these guys run off
and they start to join
the growing number of
rebel groups that are there
cropping up to oppose the
United States presence.
One of those groups is
called al-Qaeda in Iraq,
which later turns into
the Islamic State of Iraq,
which eventually becomes
the Islamic State of
Iraq and Syria, or ISIS.
A well-oiled governmental
and military organization
run by many of the military leaders
who were ousted by the Americans
from the Iraqi military
when they took over Baghdad.
So Iraq turns into the US trying to fight
this growing rebellion.
Billions of dollars turns into
tens of billions of dollars,
and then hundreds of billions of dollars,
and eventually crossing over
into over a trillion dollars
of tax payer money
to fight this unnecessary war.
Saddam Hussein was a really bad guy.
He committed mass genocide
against his own people, the Kurds.
He executed many others,
imprisoned many others.
(man speaking in foreign language)
- All in all,
the number of dead on
Saddam Hussein's hands
numbers around 250,000
according to Human Rights Watch.
That was over 25 years
of his brutal regime.
And yet in just eight years
of this war that the US started in Iraq,
way more people were killed.
A power vacuum was opened up
that allowed ISIS to thrive,
and for what?
Why did we do this?
How was this worth it?
I really believe that in the aftermath
of those towers falling,
this group of guys
began constructing a story for themselves.
A fantasy, one not grounded in
real facts from intelligence,
but one grounded in fear and
in desire to be the hero,
in the messianic complex that
always infects the powerful.
That fantasy trickled down
and spread to other people in power,
leading us into one of
the most catastrophic
and unnecessary wars in modern history.
(gentle music)
- I challenge the president
or whoever has us here for 15 months
to ride alongside me.
I'll do another 15 months
if he comes out here
and rides along with me
every day for 15 months.
- Oof, Saddam Hussein,
George Bush, Paul Wolfowitz.
What a story, what a story.
Yeah, anyway.
I wanna thank the sponsor of
the video today, ExpressVPN,
which is a service I've used for years.
When I traveled, I would
use it all the time
to basically route my connection
through the United States
so I could not be kicked out of my Gmail.
I don't travel very much anymore
so I use ExpressVPN these
days to watch Netflix,
specifically Canadian Netflix.
So basically with ExpressVPN
it's not only a security measure
that helps you secure your
connection with encryption
and all of this great technology.
The reason I like it so much
is because I can route my connection
through other countries,
and then Netflix thinks
I'm in the UK or in Canada
and I can watch UK and Canadian stuff
that isn't available on
Netflix in the United States.
This is actually the case
with a lot of different steaming services.
I love ExpressVPN.
It's super easy.
It's in the menu bar of my computer
and all I have to do is click
it and decide the country
and boom I'm there within a few seconds.
Oh, and the best part is you
can get three months of this
literally for free if you use
the link in my description.
It's expressvpn.com/johnnyharris.
When you click that link,
it helps support this channel
but it also gives you three months
literally free, zero money to use this.
Thank you ExpressVPN for
supporting this channel
and thank you all for watching.
If you want more Middle East
content, there is endless.
It's what I studied in my undergrad,
it was Middle Eastern politics,
and there's just a lot.
So I'm gonna get there,
I'm gonna get to the rest
of them if you all want it
'cause there is endless
videos I could make
for the Middle East.
Anyway, have a good day, see you.